je voudrais dire je suis vraiment très
content que christian jacob soit ici
aujourd'hui en touraine pour soutenir la
candidature de notre liste celle que je
conduis en région centre val de loire
nous devons reprendre cette région nous
devons lui redonner une nouvelle énergie
la faire repartir elle est dans les
derniers rangs des tableaux par rapport
aux autres régions elle peut redevenir
une région pilote une région de qualité
de vie pour ça il faut gagner ce combat
se mobiliser dans les derniers jours
nous avons la possibilité d'avoir enfin
une alternance que nous produirons et
c'était important que christian viennent
ici parce qu'il le connaît évidemment
très bien nos terroirs
il connaît aussi bien nous sommes ici
chez un maraîcher d'exception même très
bien le ce métier moi je voudrais que
l'agriculture toutes les agricultures de
notre région les produits du terroir les
produits transformés contribuer à
construire l'avenir de cette légion et
en face une région encore une fois
pilote une région de qualité ou fait bon
vivre
on a envie de venir s'installer et aussi
ou construit l'avenir des prochaines
générations c'est ça qui est le plus
important c'est pour cela que ce soutien
au delà de l'appui politique y est celui
de christian dans notre campagne
il est aussi un appui de fond sur le
fond qui ont une qualité de vie dans
notre région que nous sommes en train
construire nicolas avec ses listes dans
chacun des départements a réussi à créer
une vraie dynamique
on le sent sur le terrain on voit
aujourd'hui la remontée alors on le voit
bien entendu dans les enquêtes d'opinion
mais surtout on le voit sur le terrain
cette dynamique elle est créée avec une
approche qui est très terrain c'est à
dire qu'il a eu la fois la volonté
d'avoir des jeunes renouvellement très
important sur la lys à 40 ans de moyenne
d'âge
beaucoup d'élus qui ont vraiment cet
ancrage territorial
on le voit ici dans une exploitation
comme celle ci qui on est vraiment sur
le maraîchage de très haute qualité
cette région centre val de loire c'est
la grande ferme de france
on y retrouve tous n'y retrouve la
viticulture on y retrouve de l'élevage
n'y retrouve des céréales on y retrouve
un dieu du maraîchage et on voit
qu'autour de de cette agriculture et de
la filière agroalimentaire
il y a quelque chose à construire mais
au delà de ça c'est aussi une région où
il ya de l'industrie où il y a une
activité touristique qui demandent qu'à
être qu'à être développé
donc tout ça c'est le rôle de la région
et c'est ce que nicolas a réussi à faire
avec ses colistiers avec ses équipes qui
ont tous une légitimité territoriale
c'est un mandat qui demandent de la
compétence du savoir faire on n'est pas
dans les slogans on est dans le concret
pour préparer ces régions
[Musique]